(upbeat music)
- Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time, I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
I'm nervous again.
(laughing)
- Of course you are, man.
I'm nervous for you.
- We're doing what we said we would do,
which is to give a one-year follow-up
to our deconstruction stories.
And we have talked about some, you know,
we've talked on and off about
our sort of continued spiritual journey,
but we haven't gotten into it
specifically and exclusively,
and also personally and
individually in the way
that we're gonna do over
the next two episodes.
- Yeah, just to recap, one
year ago from this release,
you know, minus a couple of weeks,
we decided to launch our lost years series
where we explained about
our experience growing up
in the evangelical church,
about being fully committed to our faith,
you're already yawning.
Is that a defense mechanism?
- I'm tired, I'm bored of you already.
- Hey man, I know this
is, this is your episode.
I'm gonna let you do all the talking.
I'm only gonna ask some
questions here and there,
but when I do interject,
I would just ask that
you not yawn in my face.
- Yeah, I'm sorry.
- I think it, I think it's nervous yawn.
- Oh, I'm sure it is.
Oh, yeah, I yawn, I feel like
I have to get more oxygen.
- Okay.
- When I get nervous.
- So you're not bored with me.
- No, I'm just a little bit nervous.
- Okay. Apology accepted.
Anyway, what was I saying?
I was saying that--
- We told our stories a year ago.
- About how we, you know, how we became
professional Christians.
Well, you know, we were on staff full-time
with Campus Crusade, we
talked about all that.
There were two episodes just
to go through all the stuff
in a span of time from college
all the way through leaving
our engineering jobs
and joining Campus Crusade until leaving.
Like we filled in all of
those gaps in our career,
stuff we never talked about before.
And then now we knew
that that was basically
setting the table to then say,
to go into more depth about
each of our spiritual journeys.
And so at that time, you went
first, then I went second.
And so we're just gonna repeat that.
You're gonna go first again.
- Is that good or bad?
- I think that's good. It's good for me.
I think you're, you're breaking the seal.
You know, we're different people.
We have, we process,
we've gone through so much
of our lives together,
but we process things differently,
and you know, our friendship
has stayed intact.
Our love for one another
is strong as ever.
And I'm here to support you today
as you give some sort of update.
- Appreciate that.
- I don't want to supercharge
this any any more than it is.
And I'm curious how you've approached this
and how you've thought about it,
but I'm actually not
gonna ask that question.
I'm just gonna let you take it from here,
unless you think there's
something else to fill in the gaps
to bring people up to speed.
- No, because I will, in the course of
what I'm gonna try to say today,
I'll end up filling some of the gaps
and talking a little bit
about this, but yeah,
the only thing I'll say to kind of,
before I get started is
that I have a lot of notes,
in the same way that I did when I did it.
Like typically, you know, this is not,
this is not a scripted podcast.
This is just two lifelong friends
talking about life for a long time.
And we rarely if ever
have any sort of notes
or outline that we're going off of.
But whenever I talk about this,
and this is the ironic thing,
I just want to acknowledge
just up front is that, you know,
when I was a Christian,
when it was in the church
and when I was a professional Christian,
there were a number of times
that I had to give a talk
or even dare I say preach a sermon.
I preached a couple of sermons in my day.
- I dare you to say it.
- And I find myself
approaching these episodes
like I would getting ready to give a talk.
And I don't mean like a
pre like a preachy sermon,
but I'm just saying that like
you want to make sure that you
got all your stuff together.
And so I'm going off notes
as if I'm giving a talk,
and so I just apologize if the tone
is a little bit different
or readier than normal,
but I just feel like it's my way
of getting the right
information out there.
- Go for it.
- We ready?
At some point we'll stop
and have a little ad break,
but just keep that in mind.
Okay, so again, a year has passed
and the way I kind of approach
this is I want to talk about
some things that as I've
reflected on telling our story,
at the time that we told it,
how I've kind of processed both
the response but also
the way 2020 unfolded.
And then as I'm gonna spend
a lot of time on that,
but then I will eventually
get to sort of the update
where I'm at spiritually is
kind of what I'll end on,
which we've touched on a
little bit on a few episodes,
but I think we'll get into
it a little bit more deeply.
So going back to the initial sort of like
laying it all out there a year ago,
putting it out into the world,
the initial reaction,
very, very supportive
and encouraging on the whole,
like I would say the
vast majority of people,
even people who disagreed.
- Yeah.
- Were super supportive and encouraging.
But my response to the
minority of negative responses
was very informative about who I still am
and how much growth I
still have yet to do.
So I, you know, we have both received
a lot of negative feedback.
Doing what we do for as
long as we've done it,
being in this totally democratic platform
where you can put whatever
you want to on this place
and have whoever wants to say anything
say whatever they want to
without any sort of check
and also with anonymity,
we have, I don't know,
we never like talked about it that much,
but we have developed a thick skin.
I mean, let's just be honest.
- Well, I'm gonna, I'm not gonna admit
to changing my hairstyle years ago
because I got fed up with the comparisons
to Velma from Scooby-Doo, or
Thelma, whatever her name is.
- Well, 'cause you look just like her,
and I think it is Velma.
- Yeah.
- And I kind of look like Shaggy,
so that's not that big of a deal.
And you talk like Scooby-Doo.
(laughing)
(imitates Scooby-Doo)
But so we got a pretty thick skin.
- You're right, people will
say anything about you.
- Everything that can be said--
- They'll misunderstand
you and misconstrue
lots of things that you
intend as an artist,
as a creative person.
- An artist, we do
consider ourselves artists.
We have created some art, but--
- Could be comedians, talkers.
- Everything that can be
said about our videos,
everything that can be said
about our style of humor,
about what we look like,
every aspect of what we look like,
every aspect of our bodies,
our hands, our feet,
literally, literally
anything that can be said
about any part of us
has been said publicly.
And I've just kind of gotten over it.
- And if you think, well
that's probably great,
then you're not thinking about it enough.
- Yeah, but the one thing
that telling my story,
my deconstruction story in the fashion
that I chose to tell it,
that one thing it
invited that I have never
really experienced is
a critique of my mind.
Right, so I chose to tell my story,
which centered around sort of,
it was a largely sort of the
unraveling of my intellectual
underpinning when it comes
to Christianity, right?
And I condensed about a 20
year process into 90 minutes.
Therefore it was not exhaustive,
and it was not meant to be a dissertation
or some sort, you know, that
was not what it was meant
to be, but that was how
many people interpreted it.
Because I told this story with these steps
and I used some examples
and I actually talked about
some of the things that
were convincing to me
that sort of changed my view.
And so what that did naturally.
- People poked holes in it.
- [Rhett] Yeah.
- But what you're saying is that
given the nature of the presentation,
it was presented with holes in it.
- Well, I'll say two things.
It was presented with holes
so that any sort of like,
hey let's take this and break this down
and show all the places that he's wrong
is I wouldn't say it's a
totally fair way to treat it,
but I will say, I mean,
listen, I understood
that by saying these things,
I would be open to criticism
and my thought process
would be open to criticism,
even if you're seeing sort of
just snapshots of my thought process.
- So are you complaining about that?
- No, the point that I'm making is that
I was just reminded that like, oh wow,
you've actually grown a pretty thick skin
about what people might
say about the way you look
or what people might say about
the things that you do on the internet.
- How funny you aren't.
- Yeah, I know I'm not
funny to a lot of people,
but what I'd never done
because I've just been doing
dumb stuff on the internet for 10 years
is sort of said hey, I'm
putting my mind out there
in this way and have people critique it
and critique my thought process,
and that my pride was wounded.
And I was just reminded that
I still got a lot of pride.
I got, I have pride in
the way that I think
about the way that I think.
So ultimately, I think
that was a good thing.
It's like, if I can keep
having those edges sanded off.
- The feedback is a good thing.
- That's good for me personally.
Now, you know.
- You heard it, bring it on.
- So one of the things that,
now I know more so than you,
I've been, and again, I
think a lot of this has to do
with the fact that a lot of the critique
and a lot of the conversation
about our stories
was kind of centered around my story
because I was, my story was
much more open to critique
because it was, yours was very personal.
And who's gonna argue with your
personal experience, right?
You told us some stories,
told a lot of stories,
and it was personal and
it was super relatable.
And I was kind of saying
this thing that is like
here's the, here's how the
faith began to fall apart
for me specifically.
So I have against my better
judgment most likely,
I've read some of this stuff, right.
I've read the blog posts,
the Facebook posts,
and watched some videos.
And again, I haven't watched
anything all the way through.
I've kind of gotten the
gist of some things.
- You generated a lot of
content for other people.
- It did, it did, but one
of the things that I noticed
was that it seems that the sort of general
evangelical conclusion about us
is that we were never Christians, right?
That's where the majority
of evangelicals have landed.
That it's like, okay, this
is how I interpret this.
And this has been pretty
fascinating for me personally
because this is exactly what
I would have said about us,
you know, 15 years ago, if I were to watch
and hear the stories that
we told, I would be like,
"well, I guess those guys
were never Christians,"
or they are still and they will come back
to full faith and full
relationship with Christ
at some point in the future.
And I was thinking about that
and thinking about the way
that I used to think
about things like this,
and it was very much, it was
a commitment to Christianity.
It was a commitment to the
Bible, but more so than anything,
it was, it was commitment to an ideology.
It was commitment to a
system of ideas that, yes,
have their roots in the Bible,
but me and you both came
from a reform background.
You, like, you came from like a specific,
like your church was specifically like,
"Hey, we are reformed."
And my church was like, "we're
not a reformed denomination
but this particular expression of this
non-denominational denomination
is reformed," right?
- Yeah, post-college, newlywed,
the churches we were involved in, yes.
- Right, so we basically,
even though I was uncomfortable with it,
I kind of subscribed to
sort of Calvinism light,
you know, like what John Calvin taught.
So you've got the P in tulip,
which is per perseverance of the saints.
This is a deep cut for those of you
who don't have any experience with this.
- At least you skipped to the P.
You left the tuli on
the table, that's good.
- Essentially it's this once
saved always saved thing
that, again there's a
biblical support for it.
There's also some biblical,
there's some stuff
that might bring it into question,
but the general sort of
consensus of the churches
that we came from and the sort of the part
of the evangelical church
that we came from is that
once saved always saved.
And so I just find it
interesting that, you know,
you hear a couple of guys who
talk about their experience
with Christianity, how
they were all in for Jesus.
They recognized that they were sinners
in desperate need of the grace of God
that comes only through accepting
the sacrifice of Jesus on our behalf.
And we made a decision, in
my case multiple decisions
just to make sure it'd take,
it had taken to accept Christ.
And you say "those guys
were never Christians"
because that is what you have to believe.
The power of ideology.
But the thing that I
really want to get into
is the timing of us telling the stories.
- So before you move on, so I mean,
you're obviously asserting,
and I will, I'll agree
from my perspective too,
that experience that yeah,
I believed I was saved.
I mean, period.
I don't know what else to say.
I don't look back on that
experience and, you know,
I'm very critical of myself, but I don't,
I just don't think that, yeah,
I don't, I don't look back
at my former self that way.
And that's what you're saying too?
You think you were as
real as you could be?
I mean, did we miss something?
- What I would say to committed
evangelical Christians
who are listening is
the way that they feel
about their relationship with God
and the way that they experience
their relationship with God
is I would say, as well as I
can without being in your own,
without being inside your
body, I would say, I get it,
I relate, I understand, I
had the same experience.
And now I think very
differently about that,
and we would have
fundamental differences as to
what we think was actually
going on at that time.
But I'm saying that I understand
that if you subscribe to,
if you're still in and
you subscribe to this
particular ideology,
you do not have a choice
but to believe that we
were never Christians
or that we still are, and
we will return someday.
That's all, that's all I'm saying.
So I'm not, I'm just
saying it's interesting
that that's where people landed,
and the power of you can actually,
the way that has been discussed
in a couple of places,
the way that we have been
described as like, you know,
you can kind of tell
when you listen to them
that they never really
came to a saving faith.
They never really repented.
They never really understood grace.
It seems like it was cultural.
It seems like it was,
maybe there was an
intellectual commitment,
but it doesn't seem like they had
given their hearts to Jesus.
And as somebody who made
those same arguments
to lots of people, who talked about
it's not about a religion,
it's a relationship.
It's about a group. It's the gift.
It is the undeserved gift
of God, grace through faith.
That's the only way.
That's what I believed.
That's what I lived.
That's what I experienced.
And to be told, no, you didn't,
I'm not mad at those
people for saying that.
I'm saying I understand
that when you have,
when you've completely
bought into the ideology
you have no choice but to believe that.
Just an observation.
But the timing, the timing of our story,
what are the chances that
we told these stories
at the onset of 2020, just
before the world fell apart,
and listen, I'm very grateful
that we were able to do this
at the beginning of
what has ended up being
basically the most
difficult world for the,
or difficult year for the world at large
in our lifetimes, right?
- Oh yeah.
- Some people have suffered a lot more.
Me and you have had the privilege
of being in the position
that we are and having
the jobs that we are
so that we were able to
get through this year
relatively unscathed.
A lot of people didn't
and the world didn't
and the world is still suffering.
Two, two things about that.
First thing is
having been open and vulnerable
about our spiritual journey
gave us an opportunity to
then speak open and vulnerably
about the things that happened in 2020.
- Yeah.
- And you know, two guys who
have been in the public eye
for a really long time,
who had kept this most
significant thing secret
and off limits, we had
kind of become experts
at navigating interviews
without talking about
the elephant in the room,
which is like, "but weren't
you guys like Christians?
And not, not just Christians,
but like big Christians,
like professional Christians?
Didn't you guys write
like some Christian songs
for kids that were on like DVDs that were
in constant rotation at
Christian bookstores?"
Yes, yes, yes, and yes,
but not talking about that,
it was this weird thing
that as we continue
to get more vulnerable on this podcast
and just in life in general,
continuing to try to balance
that, not sharing that thing.
And then what became a
year where there were
certain things that our
nation and our world faced,
where the expectation was
if you are a public figure
with an audience at all,
you're going to speak into these things.
Like you can't really get away.
In 2020, you couldn't get away with
just staying on the sidelines
about a lot of things
that we went through as a nation,
but boy, it made it a lot easier
to engage in that conversation
having gotten vulnerable.
I don't, it would have
been weird to not have
had that conversation at
the beginning of 2020.
I honestly can't imagine
our interaction publicly
with the year that was 2020
without having told our stories.
- You know, I'm surprised that we're,
just as a, this is a
side note, that we were,
that we've been as
successful as we've been
and gotten to the point
in our careers we have
without being vulnerable to that level,
because that's kind of a big part of
being an internet personality.
- We wrote a whole book that was about us.
I mean, let's be honest.
We wrote the "Book of Mythicality"
that was full of stories about us.
It was memoir-ish,
but yet it didn't talk
about any of this stuff.
Because we weren't ready.
- And I do think there
was feedback like, okay,
they have more to gain
by sharing this story
than keeping it to themselves.
And you know, the people
that are suffering
are the ones who are, their faith is,
you know, is not strong enough yet.
So they're, they're
capitalizing on a vulnerability
for their own, to boost
their popularity even further
at the expense of people who
are floundering spiritually.
And it's, you know.
- I'll talk a little bit
about that in a little bit.
- Okay, we'll come back to that, but okay.
I'll just wait then if
you're gonna talk about it.
- But the, but the,
the bigger significance
- I'm grateful that, to your point,
back on point, I'm grateful
that the timing worked out
the way it did, that we were
able to talk about that.
And then it led to the conversation
in the episode we had about Ben, I mean.
- We couldn't have had
that, I mean, again.
- I just felt like it was so important.
- The biggest episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
and that's not what this
is about, but like, yeah.
- We had no clue.
- Had no clue that people
were gonna watch it
to the degree they did.
- But it was important
for us to process that
and to make it, for people
to take it how they would,
for us to process that aspect of our lives
and how our spiritual
journey had an impact on
one of the most important relationships
that we had growing up
with our other best friend.
- And we can talk all
about Ben and Ben's death,
but to talk about Ben's
death without talking about
what we were trying to do during his,
with him on his deathbed
and trying to bring him
to a decision for Jesus,
and the way that we processed that now
would have been a totally different story.
- And, yeah, to be,
to be in this medium and not
be able to be true to yourself
will eat away at your soul.
- Yeah.
- And that's, that's
why I'm grateful for it.
- Yeah, I mean, it feels, I don't know.
I would have exploded.
- Yeah.
- I would have exploded this year.
- I, I feel emotional about it
just because I'm, I'm grateful.
I mean, it's, I got a lot to
process in the next episode.
I'm not gonna, but I'm grateful for it.
And yeah, everything
that we've gone through
as a world and as a
nation that I, you know,
I'm grateful that we were able
to bring more of ourselves
to that than before the lost years series,
we were, I felt like we
were ready or capable
or had the, had the confidence to do.
- Yeah. Right.
But I think that the
bigger significance for me
was the way that my story,
in us telling our stories,
intersected with the evangelical church's
response to 2020 in general.
- Hmm. Okay.
- And I am going spend
a fair amount of time
talking about that today, but first.
- Oh gosh.
- Let's sell a feel good
Mythical Morning hat.
- This is a cool hat.
I mean, if I put it on,
I'm just gonna look stupid
'cause I don't want to mess up my hair.
- Oh, is that what it is?
- That's what matters most.
- Okay.
- Let's not forget that.
Feel Good Mythical
Morning, it comes on a hat.
It comes on a hoodie. It comes on a shirt.
It comes on all types of things.
- I think that's called a six panel.
- This right here, my friend is,
I'm super proud of what this represents.
- Feel good, man.
- That if you get, you watch
"Good Mythical Morning."
- If it feels good, do it.
- I don't care.
- That what you're saying?
- No.
- If you're saying if
it feels good, do it?
Are you a hedonist?
- I don't care who you are.
I don't care where you are.
If you watch "Good Mythical Morning,"
I believe that you will
leave feeling better.
You might feel nauseous, but
you will feel so much better
in other ways that it'll counteract it.
And that's why we want to put it on a hat,
and why you might want to wear it on a hat
or a shirt or a hoodie,
because "Good Mythical
Morning" makes you feel good.
No matter who you are or what you believe.
- Yeah, and fittingly,
this stuff does feel good.
I mean, I don't know about that hat,
but like the hoodie feels really good.
Like we pride ourselves on
soft shirts and hoodies,
sweat shirts, I'm just saying
we want things to feel good.
Why else wear something
if it doesn't feel good?
- Mythical.com.
- Okay, my story in a nutshell,
just to set the stage.
Grew up in a, just in case you haven't,
you've just decided to not go
back to the original story.
- Why wouldn't they do that?
I think they need, they'll do that.
Go ahead. Go ahead.
- Grew up in a Christian home,
made my own decision for
Christ at a young age.
Starting in high school, got
very serious about my faith,
along with this guy right here,
which continued through college.
Then after I got involved
in campus ministry,
then after college, we
eventually went on staff
with Campus Crusade to train
students in evangelism.
Now my understanding growing up,
and also well into adulthood was that
what the church believed,
which was largely based on
what the Bible said, was true.
And many things that the world,
those outside the church thought,
the things that they thought
were true were actually lies.
Right, so what we had inside
the church was the truth
and what the world had was lies.
And more specifically,
when it came to the Bible,
everything that it touches on, it is true.
It is true then, right.
So anywhere that science
and history and archeology
et cetera appears to contradict the Bible,
either that is not an actual contradiction
or the worldly philosophy
or perspective is wrong.
Like that's kind of what
I was rooted in, right.
And then, but I was also very curious
and I constantly sort
of rederived my faith
and would go back to the beginning,
because as you get exposed
to other perspectives
and worldviews which is
kind of impossible not to
in this day and age with the internet,
you continually sort of
check yourself and go back
and try to rebuild the
foundation and make sure
like, okay I want to make sure that this,
is that I can, I can derive
this, I can explain this.
I can communicate this to
myself and others, right.
But over the course of my adult
life, I came to think that
Christians might actually
have it backwards.
I, when the secular scientists,
historians, archeologists,
et cetera, questioned the truth
of something in the Bible,
they most likely were right, right?
That was the process, it
was a slow and steady shift.
And then coming to that conclusion,
which I finally got all way
on the other side of that,
coming to that conclusion
gave me permission
to question what I kind
of call the underlying
cosmic principles of
evangelical Christianity.
Namely people are born into a
broken relationship with God
and if they don't reconcile
that relationship through Jesus,
they will spend eternity and
unthinkable torment in hell.
And when I started thinking like
that's not even something
that I want to believe,
I had given myself the permission
to not have to believe it
because I didn't, I no longer
believed the underlying
sort of ideas that led to that, right.
And at that point is
when I was like, okay,
no longer consider myself a Christian.
And that happened, I
can't remember what year.
I said that was when I
went back to my story,
but you know, at least several years ago.
Now, a lot of people pointed
out that it seemed like
the two of us were not
rejecting Christianity per se,
but we were rejecting
evangelical Christianity.
- Okay.
- Right?
And maybe more specifically
Southern evangelical Christianity.
And I'll say, I somewhat agree with that
because that is what we had
and that is what we
experienced, that was our story.
And that is what we rejected.
But I will also say that, you know,
I don't think that Jesus
rose from the dead.
I don't think that God's
ultimate true manifestation
is in the person of Jesus.
And so I would say that
that puts me safely outside
of the Christian camp,
philosophically, right?
- I believe so, yes.
- So I would also say that.
So I have also come to that conclusion.
That's my, that's where I'm at right now.
That's my thinking about it.
Having said all that, I will say that
most of what I'm gonna
say today is intended
for the evangelical church,
and more specifically
the white evangelical church in America.
Because again, that's
the world I come from.
That's the world I know.
That's the world I left.
And I am going to say some
things that are difficult to hear
if you are in the white
evangelical church.
And again, I do not say
any of this to be like,
to like get back at anybody
for saying anything about me.
Again, I'm grateful for the
criticism that I received.
I am pre-grateful for the
criticism I will receive for this.
- Oh, pre-grateful.
- It continues to make me
a person who cares less
about the opinions of others,
which is a healthier person.
And it may be hard to
hear this, but I not lying
when I say that I say
these things out of love.
And I say them with a true hope
that they will ultimately
have a positive impact.
You just have to take my word for it.
Okay.
Now I haven't been part of
the evangelical church for
several, many years, it was like
six or seven years probably, but you know,
before we told our stories,
there's a lot of speculation
about us that we might be,
still be evangelical Christians,
because there was lots of
public evidence of that
from our past, you could pull it up.
- Cumulative, yeah.
- You could come to that conclusion,
and the actions of white
evangelicals in the year 2020
served as a strong
confirmation for me personally
to have publicly disassociated
myself from the church.
Now, again, I left because
I came to what for me
was an inescapable
conclusion that the church
had a spurious relationship
with the truth.
And I feel like that spurious
relationship with the truth
was borne out in 2020,
but it's more than just a spurious
relationship with the truth.
I think the church demonstrated that
it has a spurious relationship
with justice as well.
So on the issue of racial injustice,
and I'm gonna pull some data from
the Public Religion Research Institute,
this is all--
- Shout out.
- This is all straight from there.
White Christians are
nearly twice as likely
as religiously unaffiliated whites
to say the killings of black men by police
are isolated incidents
rather than part of a pattern
of how police treat African-Americans.
White Christians are
about 30 percentage points
more likely to say monuments
to Confederate soldiers
are symbols of Southern pride
rather than symbols of racism.
White Christians are also
about 20 percentage points
more likely to disagree with
the following statement:
generations of slavery and
discrimination have created
conditions that makes
it difficult for Blacks
to work their way out of the lower class.
Author Robert P. Jones, who's
also associated with the PRRI,
created a racism index that was generated
using 15 questions designed
to get beyond personal biases
and include perceptions
of structural injustice.
So basically this is a
racism test. (chuckles)
White evangelical Protestants
had the highest median score
on the racism index, as Jones summarized.
While most white Christians
think of themselves
as people who warm, who have warm feelings
toward African-Americans,
holding racist views is
nonetheless positively
and independently associated
with white Christian identity.
I don't, having spent most of my life
in the white evangelical church,
I don't need these stats,
but you might need them
in order to understand
that racism has a very comfortable home
in the white evangelical church today.
And also, newsflash, and
people who know their history
know that this is, this is not new, right?
It isn't like 2020 made the church racist.
The church has been, the
white church has been,
has held up racist ideas
and defended racist ideas
and perpetuated racist
ideas for hundreds of years.
The church, contrary,
now what we were told,
what we grew up thinking
is that, you know,
the only reason that slavery ended
was because of the
Christian abolitionists.
But what that fails to account for
is the only reason that
slavery continued for so long
was the white Protestants
who were justifying it
and doing it, right?
And, and not only that, not
only were they instrumental
in the justification of slavery,
the church was instrumental
in the justification
of segregation that followed slavery.
And Sunday morning remains
the most segregated time
of the entire week in America.
2020 just pulled the curtain back.
2020 just pulled the curtain
back on something that
lots of people have known for a long time.
- I will say, you know,
you kind of alluded to it.
I'll just say, you know, I'll
refer to your Medium article
"Letter to a White Man," because
that's where you explored
your own experience and
you wrote the letter
to your former self.
I think that, again, you
made a statement earlier
that like, given my
experience and your experience
growing up when we did, where we did,
including in the church, but
just when and where we did
in general as as white guys.
Yeah, I know a lot.
This rings true for me
from personal experience
and you know, being close
to it to the point where
I personally, I personally am
sorry for being so close to it
and unwittingly involved many times,
more than I even care to reflect
or completely understand,
because it's scary to think about,
but I talk to my kids about it, you know?
- Yeah.
- So just wanted to throw that in there.
My, this rings true from,
from my personal experience.
- And the reason this
is such a tricky thing
is because as a white Christian,
I didn't think that I had racist ideas.
In fact, I felt I had been
inoculated to racist ideas
because I believed in a
gospel that was for everyone.
There was no slave,
there was no free person.
There was no man, no
woman. There was no race.
The gospel, it doesn't discriminate,
and I thought that
because of that was true,
therefore racism can't really exist.
But what I failed to see until I left
was that so many racist ideas
were not being challenged
and actually we're being
perpetuated within our church
in ways that we were blind to.
But when it comes, we come back to 2020.
As opposed to being on the front lines
of calling for racial justice in America,
white evangelicals reliably deny
or minimize systemic racism.
And they also point out the
problems with racial justice,
racial justice protest,
rather than acknowledging
the problems that are
being protested, right?
What, and this is what I talked about
in my "Letter to a White Man,"
what does the typical white Christian,
white evangelical Christian
say about the protests?
Ah, violence is never the answer.
That, right, that's the first thing.
And a lot of times the
only thing they say,
but, okay, yeah. Violence is not good.
We don't want violence.
Violence is not productive
most of the time,
but what are people upset about?
Can we talk about that?
No. Well that's, well, that doesn't exist.
That's what we heard from again,
if you're a white
evangelical and you're like
"well, I don't believe that,"
well, a lot of people
you go to church with do.
Simply put, white evangelicals have been
on the wrong side of the fight
against racial injustice.
Okay, what about COVID?
Let's talk about COVID.
Let me just stop and acknowledge that
for many of you who are
already down the rabbit hole,
who have, who subscribe
to a Christian nationalism
and have mixed, you know,
Trumpism and Jesusism together,
nothing that I say is
going to be compelling.
In fact, and everything that
I say is going to just confirm
to you that I have completely
departed from the truth
and now live in a world of lies.
I'm not talking to you.
I'm talking to the person
who sits next to you
in church who knows better.
COVID, despite clear evidence
showing that mask wearing
helps slow the spread of COVID,
white evangelicals are
the group least likely
to wear a mask in public, least likely.
If you throw a dart at a
demographic in America,
who's least likely to wear a mask?
White evangelicals get that award.
Although the COVID mortality
numbers are within the range
predicted by scientists at
the start of the pandemic,
and hospitals have been, as predicted,
overwhelmed in many parts of the country,
white evangelicals are the
most likely demographic
to deny the seriousness of the pandemic.
White evangelicals are
also much more likely
than the average American
to question the efficacy
of vaccination in general,
and more likely to
believe false information
about the COVID vaccine.
All this is added up to
being one of the key reasons
that America has had such has had
such a tough time with COVID.
In short, white evangelicals have been
on the wrong side of
the fight against COVID.
I don't want to get into
too many more details.
I'm not trying to give you evidence
and argue if you don't believe,
if you don't believe
that COVID a real deal
and you don't believe in mask or whatever,
I'm just saying that this is what,
what is born out in America.
So in summary, white
evangelicals, largely, not all,
again, not all, but largely,
and more than anyone else,
represent an intersection
of science denialism
and racist ideas that have
made them an impediment
in the fight against both
COVID and racial injustice.
And instead of worrying about the poor
and the black and the brown
(sighs)
who are more likely to suffer
from both the pandemic
and racial injustice,
white evangelicals have been preoccupied
with their own personal freedoms,
spending more time and energy
talking about their own persecution
rather than those
actually being persecuted.
Sorry.
I don't, I'm not exactly sure
why I get emotional about it,
but I think it's because
I was such a part of it for so long.
- Yeah. I mean, yeah,
I just, I can think of,
I can see myself there and so I don't.
It hurts and it's, it's embarrassing.
- Yeah, there's a lot of shame.
- Yeah.
And it, yeah.
Yeah, and it's just not,
"oh, look at how good,
look at how righteous we are now.
Look at how woke we are now."
It's just not, I mean, it's like,
because I'm not thinking about,
when you say that, I ended up
thinking about my former self.
- I'm talking to myself.
- Yeah, and it's um.
- Yeah.
But perhaps the single
issue that best captures
white evangelicals' dubious relationship
with truth and justice
is their overwhelming
allegiance to Donald Trump.
Do I want to talk about
Donald Trump? No, I do not.
I'm so glad that I do not have
to see him in the news cycle.
You probably don't want
talk about him either,
but we can't talk about 2020.
We can't talk about white evangelicals.
We can't talk about the last four years
without talking about Donald Trump.
By far the most reliably
supportive group for Donald Trump,
Donald Trump holding steadily
at around eight out of 10,
eight out of 10, that's a lot.
You tell me there's an
eight out of 10 chance
it's gonna rain today, I'm like
"I'm bringing my umbrella."
Eight out of 10 of white evangelicals
supported Donald Trump,
both times around, 2016 and 2020.
And I can think of few
people, not just presidents,
but just few people in general
who are less Christ-like
than Donald Trump.
I mean, okay, right?
It's not, I'm not, this isn't,
I'm not being farfetched.
Yeah, he has enjoyed
more evangelical support
than even George W. Bush, who
was actually an evangelical.
Right?
And let me just say again, I
hesitated putting this in there
but listen, I'm no longer
in a part of the church,
but things could have fallen different,
a little bit different and I could,
I could still be in the church, right?
If the multi-world theory of
the parallel universe is true,
there's billions of Rhetts
that are still in the church.
Let me tell you what
those billions of Rhetts
are saying right now.
- You're annoying them, that's for sure.
- Well, no, the Rhett that is out there
in a parallel universe who is still
in the evangelical church
would not have gone along with
this Donald Trump bullshit.
I can tell you that right now.
And I lost so much respect
for so many people who did.
Now for me, the most
personally disturbing thing
is the way that Christian,
talked about this before,
Christian nationalism and
Trumpism have kind of combined
to create something that
carries the name of Jesus.
Literally, if you look
at the Capitol protest,
you see there's Trump 2020 flags
and literally Jesus 2020 flags.
I don't think he was
running for president,
but there's a flag that says "Jesus 2020"
right next to a Trump 2020 flag.
Not uncommon at all to see that,
but they've combined to create something
that carries that name of
Jesus, but looks nothing
like the Jesus that I
have seen in the Bible.
Journalist Carol Kuruvia did
a good job of contrasting
the words of Jesus with
those of Donald Trump.
So I'm gonna do that just
quickly, just take this in.
Jesus said "love your enemies.
Do good to those who hate you.
Bless those who curse you."
Donald Trump said, "when people wrong you,
go after those people,
because it is a good feeling
and because other people
will see you doing it.
I always get even."
Jesus said "for I was hungry
and you gave me something to eat.
I was thirsty and you gave
me something to drink.
I was a stranger and you invited me in.
I needed clothes and you clothed me.
I was sick and you looked after me.
I was in prison and you came to visit me."
Then the righteous will answer him,
"Lord, when did we see
you hungry and feed you
or thirsty and give
you something to drink?
When did we see you a
stranger and invite you in
or needing clothes and clothe you?
When did we see you sick or in
prison and go to visit you?"
The King will reply,
"Truly I tell you whatever you
did for the one of the least,
whatever you did for one of the least
of these brothers and sisters
of mine, you did for me."
Donald Trump said "I'm
putting people on notice
that are coming from Syria as
part of this mass migration
that if I win, they're going back."
I could go on about other things he said
that would contrast with that.
Jesus said, "those who exalt
themselves will be humbled
and those who humble
themselves will be exalted."
Trump said "sorry losers and haters
but my IQ is one of the
highest and you all know it.
Please don't feel so stupid or insecure.
It's not your fault."
- I'm not laughing anymore.
- That's almost funny.
- Yeah, but I'm not laughing anymore.
- Jesus said "do not
store it for yourselves,
treasures on earth, where
moths and vermin destroy
and where thieves break in and steal,
but store up for yourselves
treasures in heaven,
where moths and vermin do not destroy
and where thieves do
not break in and steal,
for where your treasure is,
there your heart will be also."
Trump said "part of the beauty
of me is that I'm very rich."
Okay, she actually did a lot more.
That's all I'm gonna do, I could go on.
Cheating on his pregnant
wife with a porn star
then paying her off,
bragging about grabbing
women by the pussy,
bragging about being
able to shoot somebody
on Fifth Avenue and not
lose any supporters.
Again, this is none of this is new.
You've heard it from so many people.
- I would say, I'd be tempted
to say, "you know what?
It's a little late for this. Isn't it?"
And that's, that's just
the shocking thing is that
it's not, there's still so much.
The allegiance is still there.
- Right.
- Now.
- Yeah, the allegiance is still there.
Now, listen,
I know many evangelical
Christians who recognize these
quote unquote flaws in Donald Trump,
but they say that he
stands for their interests
and he stands against
something that's worse than him
and therefore supporting
him is justified, right?
That's the position by many people.
Now, personally, I find it
hard to square Jesus's words
to turn the other cheek
with an almost obsessive
insistence that civilians
be able to carry an AR-15.
I find it hard to square Jesus's words
about feeding and clothing the hungry
with separating children from
their families at the border.
I find it hard to square Jesus's words
to the rich to sell their possessions
with supporting tax policy
that concentrates wealth
in the top 1% and gives corporations
the rights of individuals.
I can't make those two
things line up very well,
but even then, there are
still people who say,
"listen, look at what
he did with the judges.
He got three conservative
judges on the Supreme Court.
He got hundreds of federal
judges appointed, you know,
good constitutional
Christian conservatives
and therefore all in all, he's done good
even if he's a bad, flawed person."
Here's what I say to that.
My friend William Matthews
made an astute observation
about this desire for
Christians to have power,
for their interests to be represented
in the quote unquote
kingdoms of the world.
And in Matthew chapter four,
you may remember this story,
after Jesus had fasted for 40 days,
Satan took him to a high mountain,
showed him all the kingdoms
of the world and their glory
and he said to him "all
these things I will give you
if you will fall down and worship me."
Now there's a lot to that story,
but the idea is that Satan
himself was saying that like,
where I exert my power
is in the traditional
kingdoms of the world.
And he's asking Jesus "are you interested
in exerting your power there?"
And that was the temptation
that Jesus said no to.
And it seems to me, when I
look at white evangelicals
in 2021, they have
fallen to the temptation
that Jesus himself resisted.
Here's one way to say,
here's one way to see it.
If you're a white evangelical
in America in 2021,
you're no longer represented by Jesus.
You're represented by the MyPillow guy.
I mean, that's what I would think.
Because that's what I see. (sighs)
So again, so thankful that
I was able to say that
I'm not a part of this
group heading into 2020,
but I want to address
another aspect of the story.
One of the common
responses to our story was
a sense of like fear and
panic that the two of us
were leading kids astray,
that these YouTubers who
have this big audience
that has a lot of kids in
it are causing these crises
of faith to happen all
over the place, right?
And that in turn led to a
lot of people talking about
how churches and parents
need to do a better job
to train and educate young Christians
to protect them from people
like me and you, right?
- Yeah.
- I have an alternative theory about why
so many young people
are leaving the church,
because they are leaving the
church like never before.
I was gonna say I'd like
to take credit for it,
but I'm not gonna say.
What I'm saying is I don't
think it's because of me and you
and here's why, and I say this,
I mean it, I say this
out of love and respect,
because I do believe that
there is hope for the church.
Your kids are not leaving the church
because you didn't train them enough.
Your kids are leaving the church
because you trained them well enough
to develop a sense for truth and justice.
You let them read the words
of Jesus and they got it.
And they've recognized that the church
doesn't seem to be
interested in those words.
They're not leaving because
they don't know the truth,
they're leaving because they do.
This isn't necessarily something
that they would articulate.
This is something that is
happening on a soul level,
because me and you didn't give any,
we didn't give people new information
that they never considered.
There wasn't anything revolutionary.
There wasn't anything even
particularly insightful
about what we had to say
on our podcast, honestly.
Nothing that we said was,
it had all been said before.
But I think the thing that we
did is we demonstrated that
it is okay to question, it
is okay to question at all.
Your kids were already questioning it.
Because it's pretty
questionable, okay? It is.
And now they're seeing
that leaving the church
might not ruin your life.
In fact, you might find a new life.
- You know, when Lando was nine years old,
one of his favorite people on Earth
was his teacher from last year.
And she's a lesbian.
She has a wife, they have two kids.
We went to Legoland and we
happened to run into them.
This is before the pandemic hit.
And it was, you know, I
got a kick out of Lando
seeing his teacher, who he loves so much,
in a different environment, you know?
You know, it's that, there's
always that funny exchange
between a student and their
teacher out in the wild,
and it feels weird, but his
love for her was so strong
that it had the power to
overcome that weirdness.
And like, they, we got a picture together
and we would see each other in line.
We talked to each other
and like, you know,
it was amazing just that he has
that type of relationship
with his teacher.
If I would have instilled in
him what was instilled in me,
he would have not,
he would have felt deep
down within himself
that he didn't have
permission to love her.
That was my experience, you know, because,
and I know that that's, you know,
you can pick that statement
apart easily because,
well there's a difference between love--
- Love the sinner, hate the sin.
- Yeah, but I know what
the experience is like
and I know how I looked
at people who were,
who weren't straight, but the thing is,
and to your point, Lando knows,
he knows what it's like to love somebody.
That's not something that--
- It's inherent.
- And it's not something
that I had to teach him.
And the fact that he's free to love her
is a beautiful thing that I--
- And to love her fully.
- To love her fully, yes.
- When you love, 'cause again,
I'm not saying that Christians who,
there are Christians who believe,
based on their commitment to the Bible
and to their interpretation of the Bible,
that being gay is ultimately wrong,
but they say that, or gay acts are wrong,
but the person is lovable and
can be redeemed, et cetera.
But the thing that that mentality--
- It just doesn't work out
that way in your heart.
- You're invalidating a huge
part of that person's identity
and existence, and also,
in your teacher's case,
the relationship and her family
is not a valid or legitimate family.
And therefore that's not
full, it's just not full love.
- And he, and I didn't
have to teach him that.
- Yeah. Right.
- He knows, he knows what full,
wholehearted, true love for somebody is.
And I'll leave it at that.
- So if you want your kids
to stay in the church,
again this is unsolicited advice.
I don't know if anybody's
taking it, but this is not hey,
I want all your kids to leave the church.
That's not what I'm saying at all.
If you want your kids
to stay in the church,
you don't need to change your kids.
You need to change your church.
If your kids can't find Jesus,
the Jesus that they know from the Bible,
the Jesus that you've taught them about.
If they can't find him within
the walls of your church,
you know what, they will go
looking for him elsewhere.
And that may not be what
they say they're doing.
That may not be how they articulate it.
It may not be how they describe it,
but I believe that
that's what's happening.
And it's interesting because, you know,
people made assumptions
about, about me and you,
and they're making the same
assumptions about their kids.
Let me explain.
So a lot of people assume
that we left the church
because there was something out there,
something outside of the church,
whether that'd be fame,
fortune, cultural acceptance,
whatever that we ultimately
wanted more than Jesus, right?
Like we fell to the temptation
and we went after that
thing instead of Jesus.
And you also think that your
kids might want something
out there, something outside of the church
more than they want Jesus.
I think it might be simpler than that.
I think maybe your kids
who left the church
just wanted Jesus
and they saw that you
wanted something else.
They see that the church at large
seems to want something else.
Because in my experience,
and just looking at it,
and again, regardless of your conclusions
about the nature of the
historicity of Jesus
and the specific words
that are in the Bible,
but if you just take the words of Jesus,
the life of Jesus, the teachings
of Jesus at face value,
you have to do some very athletic,
very athletic mental gymnastics
to find a way to reconcile
the way the white evangelical
church looks in America today
with any of those words.
I just can't put those
puzzle pieces together
in a way that makes sense.
Okay, I stepped into a
giant pile of bull crap
and we'll see how that
airs out on the internet,
but let's move on. (laughs)
- Okay.
- In an effort to kind of finish this up
with where I'm at spiritually, right?
So I've covered some of this ground,
but just by way of just kind
of putting it all together.
You know, when I was a Christian,
I was obsessed with
having it all figured out,
like understanding my faith,
rederiving my faith over and over again,
it was a relationship with God.
But the way that I fed that
relationship was with knowledge,
knowing scripture, knowing more truth,
teaching, that kind of thing,
especially in the traditions
that we came in, came from,
you know, it's a very
mind-based tradition,
sort of the more reformed you get
in the white evangelical church,
the sort of mind-based
intellectual it gets.
And the more you kind of move into
more of a charismatic
Pentecostal experience,
it gets a little bit more heart-based.
And I never really had that.
I went to those kinds
of churches at times,
but didn't have, that wasn't
my personal experience.
But today, I see spirituality
as an openness to things that transcend
my conceptual understanding,
but are still deeply meaningful, right?
And I think that most people,
now some people don't,
some people are like
"I don't need, I don't need
faith. I don't need religion.
I don't need spirituality,"
full, full stop.
I think that the majority
of people do need something
that they might describe as spirituality.
And you know, religion sort
of represents a human effort
to systematize those
glimpses of connection
that we have with something deeper,
that leaning into the mystery.
And one of the reasons that
it's so effective at it
is that it happens in community, right?
Religions, religion happens in community.
It is like community and culture together
kind of meets faith, and the places where
it's more embedded in the culture
and more embedded in the community
are the places where it is the strongest
and like last the longest, right?
And there's this really
interesting thing that's happening
all around the world, but
it's happening in our country
as well as that, you know,
more people are moving into
a new religious category
every single year,
and that is the
religiously non-affiliated.
And there really isn't
a community for that
and I think that my prediction is that
those chickens are gonna
come home to roost.
And this idea that everybody's
gonna be disconnected
and just religiously
unaffiliated is not as,
I don't think it's a
sustainable way to move forward.
And it may take a generation
or two, I don't know,
before things come back around.
And I don't have any
predictions as to what that is,
but I kind of feel myself
in that group right now,
but as it applies to me personally.
- You're going to start a church.
- No, no, I'm not.
I'm very much not going to start a church.
But as the way that I kind of
think about Christianity now,
and again, this is all like,
I'm just kind of opening up
my mind and heart a little bit
and just saying that this, these are some,
this is some of the way
that I think about it today.
- But are you saying, just
a point of clarification,
that you think that the,
when you say it's gonna come
back around or to roost,
you're talking about
the church will change
to a point where then people
will be willing to go back in?
- That is one of several options.
That's one of several options.
I'm just saying that I
don't think that religious
unaffiliation is a sustainable condition
for the average person.
- Hmm.
- And, and I'm not,
again, that doesn't mean
that it means a return to
traditional understanding
or traditional religion.
- It might just mean a resurgence in 4-H.
- I'm just saying that if you,
and if you look at the
human makeup, right,
if you just look at the
composition of a person
and you had a way to break them down,
you would find something within them,
or just it's something that you
would interpret in the whole
that is a need for a connection
with something beyond themselves.
- A social bond, a social component.
- Well.
- A relational component.
- It might be that it's
strictly biological
and it can be satisfied
with human connection alone,
but I just don't, for
me I think that it feels
deeper and bigger than that, and so--
- But you're saying that you personally
are missing and some experience.
- No, no, well, I'm not missing it.
I'll get into that.
- Okay.
- So okay, so I think a
lot of people in the West
including me, you know,
we think about religion
in a deeply personal way,
meaning that we think about it
in terms of our individual experience
or individual destiny,
our individual soul,
and Christianity is very
individualistic, right?
And there's a lot of reasons for this.
Some of it has to do with
how much Greek philosophy
influenced the writing of Paul,
but it's been reinforced
over thousands of years
as the West has become even
more and more individualistic.
I mean, there's the, you
know the printing press
where everybody had their own
Bible and that kind of thing
and it kind of, the authority
kind of shifted away
from just a few people reading.
But this personal relationship
that we talk about
in Christianity, it's not
something that you find
much in Eastern religion.
It is kind of a Western phenomenon, right?
There's a much more of a
collective sense of identity
and also religious identity in the East
than there is in the West,
but there's this other aspect
of the way Greek thought
has influenced Christianity.
And that is this distinction
between body and soul, right?
And this distinction between
God and his creation,
and there tends to be this
idea of separateness from God
and separateness of soul and body.
And then I think that that leads to,
it continues this dualistic
thinking leads down this road
where there's a distinction between
the church and the world.
And this is just an
observation about the church.
And if you don't know, if
you're not in the church,
you may not know that this is what most,
all evangelicals believe.
You know, and this is
what I believed, which is
the church and the people, the
Christians within the church
literally have the spirit
of God inside of them.
And everyone who isn't
a believer is ultimately
left to their own devices.
That's another thing that
makes it hard to validate
someone else's experience.
When I believed that I literally had,
so there's three parts of God, you know,
the father, son, and the Holy spirit,
and when you make that
decision to become a Christian,
the Holy spirit in dwells, you,
you literally have the spirit
of the almighty God within you
leading you, guiding you.
And when you're not a
Christian, you don't have that
and so you're just a human
left to a human's devices
and human's way of thinking.
It's one of the reasons that Christians
tend not to trust people
who aren't Christians.
It's one of the reasons that Christians
tend not to trust
authorities, like, you know,
the scientists and what's
the government up to now?
- Or a plumber without an ichthus fish
on the back of his truck.
- Yeah.
- I mean, well, it is a secret code
that I think does go that deep.
- Well how can it not?
- There's God, Holy spirit's in you,
Holy spirit's in me, okay.
- If I think that I've got
the spirit of God in me
and I think that you don't, how?
That we're in, we're kind
of in a different place.
- Oh yeah.
- Right?
That's consequential,
I think that's consequential for humanity,
and I think it's one of the reasons that,
I think it's one of the
reasons that you can interpret,
and I do interpret a lot of
the actions of Christians
in 2020 as supremely selfish, right?
You know, again, regardless of
what you think about a mask,
again, the whole principle
of the mask is that
it's not full-proof, but
that it, to some degree,
depending on the nature of the mask,
which is important, it
slows the spread of COVID.
But what does it do?
It mostly prevents the spread
from the person wearing it, right?
So it is a supremely
selfless thing to wear it.
And it is a pretty selfish
thing not to wear it, right?
When it comes to the vaccine, again,
the whole idea of vaccination
is that the collective gets
vaccinated to a certain rate
in order, you know,
individuals get vaccinated
at a certain rate to
protect the collective.
And for every person who says
"well, I'm gonna see what happens.
I'm gonna see what
happens with other people"
or "I'm not doing that," again,
whether you think that
vaccines are safe or not,
like if you think that they're not safe,
you're still putting your
own safety and security
above the collective, because
you know that without it,
I'm just saying that it's a selfish act.
- And I'll even say, I mean,
we're talking about having the spirit
and then looking at those that don't,
and what that does deep down.
I've never thought about this,
but I do think it does have an impact.
It alters the equation
in how you love somebody.
I mean, or it's something
that you have to navigate,
you know, it just, you know,
if you really think about it,
how it impacts the nature
of loving somebody,
and you might say, "well, yeah, I want
I want them to be in dwelt
with the Holy spirit as well.
And I'm motivated by that,"
but there's, it's dicey, right?
There's another side to
that psychologically.
I'm just, I'm just raising the question.
We, you know, we don't have
to, we shouldn't get into it,
but I'm just observing that it,
it's a complicating factor
to someone who believes they've
been dwelt with the spirit
to love somebody who's
not, like wholeheartedly.
- And I think that the thing
that I'm seeing is that
it's not just difficult
to fully love them.
It's more difficult to trust them.
I think that that's what
we're seeing in our country,
is there is an inability to trust people
who are outside of the church.
That's why it's been
fascinating to me that
when you talk to an evangelical
Christian in light of 2020,
they think that the biggest problem
is that they are being persecuted.
They think that the biggest thing is that
there is this socialist Marxist movement
that is out to get them,
to eradicate Christianity from the earth.
to literally like if you
were to ask the average
evangelical Christian,
like what are the chances
that being a Christian will
be illegal in 25 years?
I think you would get some, I
think they'd say pretty high.
I remember thinking like that.
I thought that it was all
headed towards this place
where Christianity was gonna
become more and more illegal.
- There are biblical interpretations
that take you to that place.
- Right, and we all,
everybody who's living
always thinks that they're
in the end times, of course,
but really what I'm getting at is
this dualistic individualistic
approach to faith
is something that I have had my fill of.
I've did a lot of that, right?
And so naturally as I kind of moved,
continued to try to lean into the mystery
and be a spiritual person and
move towards spiritual things,
I'm naturally a lot more
attracted to more inclusive
ways of thinking that focus on
interconnectedness of humans
with each other and with the earth,
you know, with nature in general.
So that's what I tend
to explore right now.
And I know that sounds sort of
ambiguous, nebulous, whatever.
Ultimately what I'm saying is that
faith systems that are
built on an us versus them,
or it's like, I have
something and you need it,
versus we've all got something
and we've all got a connection
to not only each other
but to something beyond us.
I feel like not only, I'm
personally more inspired
and attracted to that right now,
but I also think it's better for the world
and where we're at as a species.
Now, when I told my story,
I used the infamous analogy of saying that
Christianity was a ship in the ocean
and that I jumped off of the
ship into a sea of uncertainty
and I dragged my wife
and my children with me.
I talked a little bit about
this on the Christmas episode,
about how I regretted that
analogy for a number of reasons,
chiefly is what it made it seem like
I was saying about my wife.
I was making it seem
like my wife and my kids,
but especially my wife had no agency,
that well, whatever the guy decides,
the girl has to go along with it.
It's like, and I regret even implying that
because my wife Jessie has, (chuckles)
just go to her Twitter account
if you're interested in seeing
her exercise her agency.
(laughing)
LosFamgeles, L-O-S-F-A-M-Geles.
- I hope she adds that to her Twitter bio,
exercising my agency.
- Meaning that Jessie has her own story.
I think she'll tell it at some point.
And Jessie is, she is,
to characterize what she
went through is some sort of
me leading our family down a
road to question Christianity
and her coming along for ride is a,
is a very large misrepresentation
of what actually happened.
I may have been the first person to ask
some of the tougher questions,
but she has had her own
distinct journey in many ways
much deeper and more
significant than my own.
And she's challenged me in a lot of ways
and also been really instrumental
in my own personal spiritual growth.
So it isn't about me leading
my family into despair,
but I also regret the analogy a little bit
because I didn't fully
explain what, you know,
having reflected on it, the
point that I was trying to make
was also that the ship on
the ocean of uncertainty
that seemed to have a purpose
and seemed to be like,
there's a bunch of people on that ship.
I believe that was an illusion
of certainty and security.
I don't believe that the ship existed
or that it was just a collective of people
who decided to gather
together, and I don't believe
that it actually
represented the foundation
that I thought that it did.
That's why I jumped.
But I was recently listening, you know,
one of my favorite
philosophers is Alan Watts.
And, you know, he's like
a '60s-based writer,
professor, I don't even know
really what his background was,
but he's just, he's just a trippy dude
who says a lot of things
that sort of expand your mind
and make you think
about things differently
and I enjoy listening to him
and just, again, just like having my mind
kind of like challenged and expanded
because of the way that he sees the world.
And I wouldn't say that it's necessarily
a spiritual practice to
listen to Alan Watts.
It is somewhat, but for
me, it's kind of just fun.
- It's certainly a philosophical practice.
- Yeah, right, and it is
an expansive way to think.
And he does talk a lot about
things that I relate to
as I consider where I come from
and where I might be going,
spiritually speaking.
- He'll filter the Western point of view
through Taoism, Buddhism,
he'll kind of give you a
primer on those things.
- And that's it, and so he
was talking specifically
about this and he used the same analogy
of jumping off of a ship.
Or he may have said a rock,
but what he was saying is
that if you read the Bible,
the analogy is used for Jesus
and just the faith in Christianity,
it's a rock, it's a foundation,
it's a steady, stable thing
that you need to be on.
You need to be rooted.
You need to, you know,
you need to be planted
in a sea of uncertainty so
that you can kind of withstand
all the things that
life would bring at you.
And he was saying in
contrast to that, you know,
Buddhism kind of represents
jumping off of that foundation
into a sea of nothingness.
And he says the only way to survive
in the sea of nothingness is to swim.
And the only way to swim is to relax.
You know, if you're drowning in the ocean,
a lot of people say
that if you can't swim,
don't just go crazy, you'll
sink if you just start trying
to tread water, the most humans float,
if you just relax and float,
your head will stay above water.
And I was like, man, this
is a, this is a kind of,
this is a great way to sort of reinterpret
and reapply my analogy because
I don't feel like I'm
in a sea of uncertainty.
I feel like I'm free. Right?
I would mostly describe
where I'm at right now
as there is a sense of
lightness and a freedom,
Ironically, that is the
way many Christians,
especially people who have, you know,
we didn't have the privilege of having
like a hardcore testimony
like some people,
you know, every once in a while
when people did testimony
time, you got like the guy
who was like, I was in
The Church of Satan,
and I was a biker and I killed a boy.
(laughing)
- Oh gosh.
- And then I found Jesus
and now there's a sense
that a burden has been lifted off of me.
And when you grow up in the
church, you don't get that.
You don't have that crazy, I was crazy
and did all this stuff,
and now I got Jesus.
But the way a lot of
people describe the moment
of coming to faith there's a sense that
a burden has been lifted off of them
and there is a lightness
and they feel free.
I'm not arguing with that,
especially if you've got
a background where you,
you know, you were all about yourself
and then you gave yourself
to something else.
But I just find that
to be ironic that the,
for me, the leaving and also
being vocal about my leaving
has been the sense of freedom,
the sense of lightness, the
sense of not being burdened,
the sense of being open,
and the sense of not feeling threatened.
I think one of the things that
was so true of my experience
as a Christian was that
everything was a threat.
Everything was a threat.
You think this? Well, that might be scary.
You might be out to get me.
You might be bad for me.
- I know where that leads.
- Yeah.
- Kind of a thing.
- And what I have found
is that, you know what,
when I jumped out of
the ship of Christianity
into the sea of nothingness, (chuckles)
which still may be a bad analogy,
it's not like my moral
compass was on the ship.
I think a lot of people live
with the understanding that,
well, no the compass on the ship.
If you leave the ship, you
don't have the compass anymore.
It's like, no, you, you still, you got it.
It's actually, unless you're
just biologically predisposed
to be a horrible person,
most people have a pretty
intact moral compass.
And that sense of truth
and justice that your kids
naturally have, that your
kid, that Lando naturally has.
And it's been interesting
to navigate the world
in a way that it doesn't mean that
my guard is completely down.
I still, in fact, one of the things
that I've gotten better at recognizing,
especially through therapy,
is malignant narcissism.
As someone who is at least
somewhat narcissistic myself,
you know it when you see it,
but malignant narcissism and the idea that
somebody is ultimately about
themselves above all things
is something that any
organization, any system
is a breeding ground for
narcissists to rise to the top.
And the church has no exception.
The story of the mega church
pastor who falls from grace,
which is just, you know,
every month or every year
there's gonna be another
big story like that.
It's a case of malignant narcissism
being rewarded in the church.
And I think that I've actually
gotten better at recognizing
people who are out for themselves
and people who actually
are a threat to me,
my family, and my wellbeing.
And then to realize
that a lot of the people
that I thought were threats,
and a lot of the ideas
that I thought were threatening are not.
And that is, I don't know, man,
I'm just having a lot more fun
as a human than I did before.
And that doesn't mean that I'm--
- Dirty fun?
- Doing a bunch of wild things that would,
that would blow your mind if I told you
and you know, compromise who I am
and you know, end my
marriage, no, far from it.
And, but I will say that,
so the idea that Christianity
is kind of about, you know,
it's foundational, it's a rock,
you kind of got it figured
out and you go from there,
moving away from that
into a more open place
that doesn't have a system or a structure,
I don't know, this may be a season,
because I also don't
think necessarily that
a systemless way of going
about things spiritually
is sustainable, which kind of
gets back to what I just said
which is this whole
religiously unaffiliated.
So I don't know what this
means for me personally.
Right now, it means that I'm reading
a lot of different things,
listening to a lot of different things,
and having what I would describe as
significant spiritual experiences.
And again, a lot of these things
are not things I want to
talk about explicitly.
They're kind of ineffable
and I feel like you can take
a little bit of the magic
away from them when you
start trying to explain them
and put them into human words.
But I do think that spirituality
is best experienced in community.
And I think the idea
that I'm just some guy
who like listens to something
on my headphones by myself
and that's my spiritual experience
is not the end all be all.
I think one of the things that the church
does very very well is community.
And I think that we need community.
We need connection.
And I think that any true
religion, any true faith,
any true spirituality is going to be about
benevolent connection between people.
It's not gonna be about hierarchy.
It's not gonna be about
one narcissistic dude
making all the rules in charge,
which happens in systems a lot of times,
but true benevolence in grace with,
from one person to another.
And like my wife and I experience that
you know, as we have spiritual
experiences together.
But again, I think that ultimately,
and I don't know when this will happen,
but I think that it's got to happen
in the context of community.
But as soon as you apply
labels and systems to it,
humans get involved and
end up doing the things
that humans do, which is
they establish the hierarchy.
They reinforce the patriarchy,
the narcissists rise to the top.
So there's some interesting
conversations going on
and have been going on for years
about what does this mean for the church?
Like if the church, you know
really wakes up from its,
from the nightmare, and
again, there's lots of people
who would say "listen
guys, you're just still
talking about the evangelical
church or Protestants
or, you know, there's
actually a lot of people
who call themselves
Christians who are already
where you're talking about
and come be a part of that community."
I'm not saying that I
won't, I'm not saying that
that's not gonna happen.
So far, I haven't gotten to
a place where I feel like
I could comfortably reenter
that kind of environment
that is saturated in Christian
language, ideas, and imagery,
and not just go back
to the individualistic,
dualistic way of thinking about things.
So maybe there's a community out there
where you can kind of
experience the openness
and the expansiveness
and it's about connection
with each other and something
beyond your collective self,
'cause I'm not interested in saying,
"Hey, I'm gonna go be a Buddhist.
I'm gonna go and be a part of a tradition
that I have no knowledge of."
And you know what I'm saying?
Like, I don't think the answer
is to go find another system
or subscribe to some new faith
and become like a
inductee into some other,
you know what I'm saying?
Like that doesn't feel right right now.
So I don't know, a lot
of it is up in the air,
but I don't feel an emptiness right now
and I don't feel like this great desire
to immediately define what
it is that I'm experiencing,
to try to invite other people into it.
I'm not, I'm trying not to
be evangelistic about it.
I tend to be evangelistic in general,
meaning that I try to share and persuade.
And I'm trying not to do that
with what I'm experiencing
and probably the fact that I don't,
you can't even really put your finger
on what I'm saying about it
was probably helpful
to that end, but yeah,
that's kinda where I'm at right now,
is there's just this anticipation
that we're all moving in a direction.
And I want to, you know, I want
to be where the magic's at.
- Oh, okay. That's a good
place to end with, magic.
You're gonna become a magician.
- Yeah, right.
- Well, you know what?
Well thanks for coming in, Rhett.
We will talk to you again a year from now.
(laughs)
I mean, how do you feel at this point?
- (sighs) I don't know, man.
- Okay.
I appreciate, you know,
I appreciate you pulling
all your thoughts together,
and you know, I think he put a lot of,
a lot of care into it
and I appreciate the honesty
in the way that you're processing it
and yeah, I'm here if you
want to talk some more.
But I mean, to that end, I mean,
next week I need you to
hold my beer, all right?
- Yup.
- You know, I've been putting
a lot of thought into it.
And I think that, you know,
as you've talked about your experience,
I'm gonna kind of pick up from that spot,
you know, like the last section
and just kind of run with
it with my own experience
and just process, you know,
it's been a difficult
year in a number of ways.
So dealing with suffering, loss,
there's been a lot of tests,
you know, tests of faith
I might call them.
I definitely would have
called them that in the past.
- Yeah.
- So, you know, I want to,
I've got some experiences I
want to share and process,
you know, in terms of
my spiritual journey.
And if you're willing to join me,
that'll be next week.
So I'll give it a go.
- And, you know, like I said,
we're not always gonna
devote an entire episode
to talking about these
things, but we'll keep,
we will keep talking about these things
in general as well, and want to,
and your words on the internet
about this conversation
and entering into this
conversation are encouraging.
And again, it's not, it
doesn't have to be encouraging.
It could be a critique.
It could be a question.
- #EarBiscuits.
- Just get involved in the conversation.
- And incorporate so that we'll,
it'll be easy for us to find.
- And my rec, I'll end with a rec.
I've kind of already made it,
and I think that that
is gonna be Alan Watts.
There's a number of ways
that you can find his work.
One of the ways is if you just go,
Alan Watts as an artist on Spotify
and someone, I know
that his son is involved
in like maintaining his foundation.
- That's AlanWatts.org and .com I think.
- Someone has taken some of his,
he just did a bunch of
lectures that were recorded.
Somebody has taken some of his lectures
and put them with music on Spotify.
And again, if you're just looking for
a mind-opening, expanding experience,
it's just a trip to listen to this dude
and the way he chooses
to think about things
and chooses to communicate about them.
And I highly recommend it for anybody
who just is up for that
kind of experience.
- All right. You did it.
Go take a shower or
something. I don't know.
- Do I stink?
- No, I'm just, I'm just trying to
just give you just something
to look forward to.
- Okay. All right.
Well, lunch.
- #EarBiscuits, y'all,
we'll speak at you next week, get ready.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.
(funky music)